sometimes things are canceled in the
sense that people are fired or a Show is
canceled or someone is ostracized or
people change their views or activists
Express opinions that say I don't like
what you said that happens right that
takes place but does the cancel culture
that Republicans describe actually exist
Does this culture exist when Republicans
scream we are being canceled by the woke
left I believe that it does not really
exist often what is happening is that
someone's words or actions are having
consequences as those words and actions
are being evaluated in the free market
of ideas which Republicans claim to
support oftentimes the canceled still
have a bully pulpit
plenty of access to corporate media
social media and other platforms to
spread their views